all right so you're going to you don't
need your B in you want to put your
mind and that includes your tips the tip
into the mid foot so when you pick it up
you're pushing down on that on that mid
foot don't try to get leverage here you
should
feel pushing that okay
good I feel that weight he's amplifying
the way so I can feel it okay and I
picked that up with those mechanics you
don't have to make it like he's trying
to shove down just some awareness there
okay little more than that okay you feel
it and you pick it up using it that way
so you hold
it when he tries to pick it up I'm not
going to sit here like that I just want
Amplified weight for you to pick it
up okay so don't do what he
did just amplify it for them to feel it
get it in the foot and you keep a
constant pressure release it again
but this is too light it's enough let it
charge and then he's lifting
that up as you're going okay right all
right let's try
that all right so we
have this uh drill right she's you don't
have to stand in that right and I'm
grounding in the horse okay and we have
drill where they climb up the elbow and
I'm gling the horse stance she comes up
to the shoulder you don't need that
angle here okay and I'm grounding in the
horse stance and because the corner is
not
important okay I'm grounding in the hor
okay so you'll give me the
[Music]
grounding and he'll give me that okay so
because the energy is the same
young aspect is being ground Vector so
this should not move me and that's the
one I'm using to lift the sword okay so
I'm not going to hit I don't want to hit
her in the face but you'll have to me
this is the drill when you when when I
lift his the tip uh the drills there but
we're going to exaggerate a little bit
and we'll come up
as far as I can without knocking her arm
off my chest
okay okay let's try all right now you
don't have the
amplification but you want to increase
your s ativities you still have weight I
still have
my weight there's young aspect in the
bulen and that's what picks
up we're not going to do other
things those they're all different okay
all right so you should feel the tip
already and you're already holding it
with your mid foot you're already
holding it and it
moves with that mid foot
Vector oh feel it feel it feel it feel
it feel it you'll feel it go to the in
face boom come back down and you'll
catch it again coming back down on that
mid foot okay try